welcome to the NewsHour we begin in
eastern Libya where it's feared hundreds
have been killed in floods caused by
storm Daniel now the worst affected city
is thought to be derna where authorities
say two dams burst in the heavy rainfall
and that's at a wall of water down a
valley and through the Port City roads
buildings and bridges have all been
destroyed storm Daniel brought the
heaviest amount of rainfall in a single
day in nearly 40 years Olivia's rival
governments have both announced three
days of national Mourning
let's join Malik trainer joins us now
live from uh Tripoli three days of
national mourning really isn't going to
help the people that need that Aid and
need that government support despite
which side of the political spectrum
they are from they need it now what is
getting there Malik if anything at all
thank you
well we saw a large Convoy of Aid
including excavators bulldozers large
trucks ambulances medical staff hundreds
of volunteers leaving Western Libya
early this morning they should have
arrived already in eastern Libya we're
also seeing people come together from
the East volunteers are trying to reach
the the most impacted areas like you
said the city terna is believed to be
the most impacted I mean we're starting
to hear the word catastrophic so
delna is a port city so you have the
beach of the Mediterranean Coast here
and on three sides is the mountain in
those mountains is a major Dam that
collapsed sending of what experts
believe more than 30 square cubic meters
of water into the city I mean the
pristine pictures of entire
neighborhoods washed away uh but as of
now authorities have not been able to
reach the city Eastern officials are
talking about numbers of thousands of
people missing feared dead so until the
assistance until authorities are able to
reach the city of delna we're not going
to know uh that how devastating uh This
Storm was for the city we've we've seen
since last night pictures across Eastern
Libya in the city of el-badan shahad and
so many cities towns and Villages
scattered across this wide and spread
out area have been impacted uh and we we
we we we saw those things and we and
please check out this report
entire neighborhoods flooded across
Eastern Libya the worst storm the
country has seen in years Mediterranean
storm Daniel brought record rainfall
in the city of El baida people can only
watch as their vehicles are washed away
patients and staff were forced to
evacuate several hospitals local
officials are calling for immediate
assistance
we announce with regret that the
situation is completely out of control
we call on all government officials to
intervene to save what can be saved
governments are responsible for people's
lives request the security services to
provide assistance
Libya has been engulfed by political
divisions for more than a decade the
country has two governments that slowed
down emergency assistance efforts
the parallel government in eastern Libya
has announced a two-day state of
emergency
enforcing a curfew and calling for
people to exercise caution if they leave
their homes the internationally
recognized government in Tripoli
declared Eastern Libya a disaster Zone
it sent teams of emergency workers from
Western Libya
I've instructed the Ministry of Health
and all relevant agencies to quickly
provide assistance relief convoys will
be dispatched to all cities affected by
this incident will respond with all
available resources
the impact of storm Daniel on Eastern
Libya has been devastating local
officials say many people remain missing
with search and rescue operations
currently underway there are fears the
death toll will only rise and
forecasters have issued a red warning
saying more storms are on their way now
trainer Al Jazeera
you've been joining me now is Dr Hani
shanib he's originally from the city of
dhana in Libya he's also the president
of the National Council on U.S Libya
relations and joins us now from Phoenix
in Arizona over in the U.S good to have
you with us sir on the program can you
before we even sort of talk about the
disaster just describe to us uh derna
and the the the geography of those dams
that seem to have burst and affected the
area
well thank you for having me and
unfortunately there are not a lot of
voices that can be brought up from derna
because everything is cut off completely
there's no internet connection there's
no electricity and the magnitude of the
disaster that has happened in the city
is just growing by the minute uh just
think about it initially When comparing
it to what happened in Morocco where the
initial report stated that there were
about 300 casualties from the earthquake
we now are basically dealing with an
initial report where more than 2 000
individuals have lost their life in this
city and the numbers are expected to
grow much larger than this to at least
five thousand victims so this is a city
that is cut off completely from the
world it is beleaguered by the fact that
there is no proper governance in Libya
in a failed state that has struggled
over the last 12 years and unable to
basically provide the basic structure in
a stable condition let alone a disaster
that has happened very quickly in during
is a city of about 180
000 individuals a city that routes back
to the days of the Inquisition in 1492
when most of the migrants that build the
city are originally from the endelese
region in Spain they build a beautiful
city and unfortunately over the years
have actually degraded economically
because of the resistance of Gaddafi so
you can see that they start behind and
now they have two dams that were
constantly flooding the city there was
one Dam that was a very small one and
with that they were encountering they
were encountering several floods a year
but they were very small floods in the
60s until the kingdom decided in the
late 60s to build a larger Dam
unfortunately with the tail end of the
Danielle storm
uh there has been a sudden abrupt
increase and the water load which led to
the total Destruction of the major Dam
and the sudden flooding of the city to
the extent that uh about four square
kilometers of the Heart of the City have
been eroded completely okay doctors that
have been totally destroyed let me just
jump in there because basically you
you're painting the picture for us uh
brilliantly how what sort of
communication have you been able to to
get from anybody from the area you say
internet connection is bad and so are
telecommunications but you're getting
your information from somewhere where is
that
so the communication is proper is is
primarily through very limited access
through individuals that have zarya
phones that can actually Outreach uh
without uh without uh uh internet uh
they're also families and and as you
know Libya is very tribal so their Word
of Mouth from families uh that are very
close in the vicinity of the city that
are reaching out trying to reach out in
different ways to the inside of the city
the city itself is a mountain is on the
skirt of the mountain so for you to get
into the city there are basically two
major roads from the East and West that
climb down to the city from the mountain
there's only one little road that is
left in there and uh and and again the
families are coming in there they're
trying to look for their families I
personally have 20 members of the chenee
family that are unaccounted for so they
the tragedy that is happening in there
is not only
absent from the International Community
but it's also there's some challenges in
reaching out to inform the world of what
is happening in the city today we'll
certainly try and find out more as we
get it but you certainly painted a very
Grim picture for us Dr honey thank you
for your time and joining us from
Phoenix and Arizona
Let's cross over to uh Goma al-ghamati
head of the Terre party in Tripoli it's
good to have you with these uh good to
have you with us on Al Jazeera so the
tension politically between east and
west of the country is evident how are
the two administrations coordinating
efforts to help people in the East and
in derna
well I think
Adams of Qatar
qatars Rising above all these political
differences and polarizations and coming
together to help on this humanitarian
challenge so I think people are
mobilizing from the east from the west
from all over Libya to try to you know
Ferry and take whatever they can in
terms of equipment and supplies to those
cities in the East but especially the
hardest hit city which is dharna which
as you guess just mentioned it's very
difficult to get to and the information
is that it's really disastrous there
it's a catastrophe there is a lot of
damage a whole residential areas have
been pushed into the sea and there could
be definitely hundreds that and possibly
thousands missing until now and it so
all those supplies and all those
equipment it's not easy to get them to
inside there also whether it's the
whether it's the government in the East
which is not which is not recognized
internationally or the government in
Tripoli which is recognized I think what
is needed is far beyond the means of
those two governments I think what we
need is an international mobilization uh
to help especially the city of dharna
but other parts of this of the city that
is going to be very difficult isn't it
to appeal to the International Community
when there are these two administrations
in the country uh and have Unity on what
is a an Emergency how do you expect the
International Community to react and who
should they be reacting to Tripoli or
the Eastern Administration
yeah
well I think this this disaster as I
said transcends all differences and live
yeah and everybody will cooperate with
any support or any rescue that can come
from outside Libya it is known that over
the last 12 years many many countries
have been interfering in Libya
unfortunately most of the time
interfering detrimentally and supplying
weapons and arms so now we need them to
interfere constructively and positively
by supplying us with badly needed
equipment sophisticated equipment and
badly needed humanitarian supplies and
whether they deal with authorities in
the East or in the in the west they'll
find that everybody every Libyan will
cooperate with them to help those
beleaguered those who are stuck in those
disastrous areas it is very important
now to save as many people and to try
we'll understand Mr
alkamati one understands that that's
what you're appealing for let's get to
the nitty-gritty what is Tripoli sending
now what are political aids to you and
the political hierarchy within the
capital there to telling you about the
aid and the equipment that is going to
the east what do you actually know
well we know that the government in
Tripoli or the municipalities on all the
civil defense and all the the medical
care and and fire brigade and all those
Civil Authorities and civil services
that normally help on these disasters
have all mobilized last night and today
and they're all uh care taking all the
needed supplies and equipment to the
east to those areas and and I think the
authorities in the East the
municipalities in each City and each
town are also cooperating so help will
be welcomed doesn't matter whether it's
coming from Tripoli or coming from
outside Libya health will be welcomed
and people at the at the at the site of
the disasters will cooperate and will
try to facilitate that help to reach the
the needed people and the needed Parts
at the moment
let me just let me just let me just get
in there how do you assess what is
needed because there is food and shelter
as one form of Aid and there is also the
aid of logistics mending roads and
bridges that have been washed away who
makes that valid assessment and who who
understands that appeal and who makes
that appeal to the International
Community if Tripoli or if Libya itself
doesn't have that heavy equipment to
repair the roads and the routes so the
logistics of Aid can get to the
locations of the disaster
I think the appeal is already out it's
an international media doesn't have to
be an official request we've helped some
countries have now in the last hour
indicated that they are willing to help
I hope others will come forward as well
as long as those countries are willing
to help and make an initiative and come
forward and say they are ready to to to
to send required equipment and and and
other form of of help I think uh all the
needs to facilitate that will be will be
provided locally I think we need
equipment digging equipment uncovering
collapsed buildings possibly even
picking bodies or or say or people who
are floating or people who are stuck in
the sea people are stuck under buildings
that kind of equipment I think food and
shelter is probably the least we need
food can be supplied locally but
sophisticated equipment to detect people
under the Ripple to dig to to repair
roads quickly to even set up temporary
roads so that we can have access to a
place like dharna which is now
completely cut off that is the kind of
need where the help we need I think this
only International Community only
certain countries or other countries
than Libya can provide this
sophisticated equipment and quickly I
think the logistical operation needed
requires International intervention okay
authorities in Libya whether it's in the
East or in the South or in the west are
not really in a position to provide
these sophisticated equipment and
logistical support we'll see what
happens uh what does come in uh
government alga Marty thanks so much for
joining us from tripolisa